on our special correspondent Alex
Crawford is in the southern city of
Adana tonight Madonna Alex tell us
what's happening in Adana this evening
experience quite a lot of damage all
around this area 30 mile radius at least
have been very badly affected behind me
you can see the mobilization of
literally hundreds of people who've
flown in from around the country to try
to help because this is turning into a
massive humanitarian emergency aid
Expedition with temperatures expected to
dip in this region to below minus 30 in
some cases with me is undash is one of
the volunteers who's come to try and
help how much does this mean to you how
how big is the scale of This Disaster as
far as your concerned
excessive in the career of the Earth Day
but I think there is a big disaster
[Music]
and
come through
had
I mean president erdogan the Turkish
leader has called this the worst
earthquake in maybe a century yes the
World Health Organization is talking of
the number of dead reaching 60
000 potentially I mean we're talking
about a huge disaster there's a huge
investor in this area and we have come
to a
foreign
thank you for talking to us at such
short notice very good luck with your
mission so you can understand that this
is a massive expedition to try and
rescue as many people as possible they
say that the first 24 to 48 hours are
absolutely critical and
basically the whole country is eyes are
focused on what's happening in this area
with something like 45 different nations
offering their help to Turkey it's going
to be a very long night and long few
days ahead